it's good to wear sunscreen year round
but it is really the time of year for
sunscreen right now you may have heard
FDA warnings about chemical sunscreens
which can cause skin irritation and
other issues that's why it's best to use
a mineral sunscreen like the one by
Ginger armor it is just as effective
much safer and you'll save 15 percent
with the code Pacman the link is down
below
today is the day that Ron DeSantis
launches his presidential campaign
entering the Republican primary against
the presumed and actual it's funny
presumed he's really the front runner
Donald Trump and we will soon start to
learn is there some viable path for Ron
DeSantis to the Republican nomination
the details are fascinating and abortive
Ron DeSantis is going to be launching
his campaign on Twitter
in a Twitter spaces event with Twitter
owner Elon Musk NBC news reports the
Florida governor will announce he is
running for president on Twitter
Wednesday evening in a conversation with
Elon Musk we will be streaming this Live
on YouTube twitch and Facebook I hope
you will join us for that
um NBC News explains musk and DeSantis
will host an event on Twitter spaces the
site's platform for audio Chats on
Wednesday at six Eastern it will be
moderated by David sacks a tech
entrepreneur who's a musk Confidant and
DeSantis supporter that same evening
meaning tonight the campaign will
release a launch video DeSantis will
begin visiting several early States
after Memorial Day the relationship
could could is doing a lot of work here
the relationship could be a significant
boost for DeSantis by giving him an
introduction to and credibility with
musk's massive following including his
140 million Twitter followers but it
could prove a burden should DeSantis
become distracted by the tycoon's many
controversial comments not only that I
mean listen let's be honest Ron
desantis's entire anti-woke thing is not
actually uh very much in line with Elon
Musk Tesla electric vehicles we're we're
not gonna go woke with these electric
vehicles you can't even drive right I
mean it doesn't actually make any sense
but also musk has started to
play koi with Republican elected
officials becoming buddy buddy with Greg
Abbott in Texas Etc so it's going to be
quite a wild event and I'm as curious as
anybody else you know one of the things
that we have to understand Twitter
spaces why my understanding is there
will be absolutely no pushback or actual
journalistic questions asked on Twitter
spaces tonight and that may be by Design
it's not clear DeSantis wants to answer
questions tonight including the most
obvious and basic question which is what
is desantis's mathematical path to this
nomination because if we look at current
polling here's the real clear politics
averages in the 2024 Republican
Presidential nomination what you see
here the two most important lines on
this chart
are the purple line at the top which
keeps going up that's Donald Trump and
the green line down the middle which
keeps going down that's DeSantis and
DeSantis continues to see small declines
in polling now down to just 19.4 today
Trump's lead over DeSantis in the
primary is
I think as big as it has ever been I
mean at one point it reached what looks
like 32. yet Trump is now leading
DeSantis by 37 in the primary
that's that this is arguably the worst
it has looked for DeSantis since his
name started to be thrown around
seriously back in September and so the
question is how can DeSantis scoop up
all of the non-trump vote which would
get him to 44 43-44
and then if and when he does that how
does he take
at least six or seven points from Trump
to get even with him I don't know the
answer you know when we ask the question
generically right how does a candidate
take supporters from another candidate
uh there's a few ways one is you explain
DeSantis could explain his values in a
way that would appeal to the moral
beliefs of trump supporters like he
could frame his policies on immigration
or health care or education or whatever
he could frame it in terms of individual
Freedom or national security or being
anti-woke or whatever he thinks will
appeal to Maga people it doesn't really
sound likely it doesn't sound to me that
Maga voters are there waiting for
someone else to appeal to them on the
moral values that attracted them to
Trump just doesn't seem to really make
sense second possibility to take support
from a candidate that already has
support would be can you gather up
enough endorsements
from influential enough figures that
Trump supporters trust and respect that
they say hey you know what it's less
about Trump and DeSantis it's the people
that I see endorsing DeSantis makes me
makes me think I should leave Trump and
go to descendas it again doesn't seem
likely because we just looked at this
story more than 100 former Trump
officials are supporting DeSantis we've
seen a number of prominent Republicans
say we need a different direction than
Trump Maga genuinely doesn't seem to
care so that doesn't seem like a path
for DeSantis to take support from Trump
and then the third way you can take
support away from someone who has it is
you make a mathematical case you make an
empirical case you make a polling case
and you say I am the person that is best
positioned to beat Joe Biden you
convince Maga people with Trump you lose
to Biden with me you win
I honestly don't even know that that
would convince Mega voters even if it's
true because on Friday in the Friday
feedback segment we're going to look at
emails from Trump called this who say I
don't care about anything I will only
vote for Trump and that's it and so that
also doesn't seem to be a convincing
argument that DeSantis could make to
take support for Trump and again
remember the reason this matters is
Trump's already polling 56. so to win
DeSantis has to take supporters from
Trump I don't know how he does it so
we're going to look at the event tonight
we'll see what happens should be
interesting we'll see what role Elon
Musk plans to play in the DeSantis
campaign more broadly uh it seems as
though with musk behind him
Twitter is going to be potentially a
strong force supporting DeSantis but
would that be enough would that make a
difference we will see in the meantime
Trump Brown nosers and suck-ups are
starting to do the dirty work for Trump
in attacking Ron DeSantis one of those
people is Carrie Lake let's talk about
that next
one of the
things that has been said about Trump's
2024 campaign is that he's going to pick
a female running mate and the names that
keep being tossed around
primarily are
um Nikki Haley in no particular order
Nikki Haley Carey Lake Marjorie Taylor
green and Christy gnome
of those I genuinely have no idea which
is the most likely one of the craziest
is Kerry Lake and Kerry Lake does seem
very desperate to be Donald Trump's vice
presidential running mate and so she is
wasting no time remember that tonight
Ron DeSantis is going to be announcing
his candidacy against Trump in the
Republican primary uh Carey Lake getting
a jump on the character assassination
appearing last night on Newsmax and uh
saying if DeSantis can't even beat
Disney how is he going to beat Donald
Trump
certainly seems to be auditioning for
vice president let's take a listen but
we can't do it half-assed when you pick
a fight with Disney you need to play to
win and so far Governor DeSantis has
been outworked and outmaneuvered by
Disney as far as I know Reedy Creek is
still exists they're still hosting trans
events at their park what is a trans
event exactly this indoctrination is
continuing and they're actually rubbing
it in the faces of American families you
know if you can't beat Donald Duck how
are you going to beat Donald Trump whoa
that's pretty slick as far as a line
goes I think that's the question we have
to ask when it comes to Governor
DeSantis and I think you should stay in
Florida and continue fighting for the
people there and try to finish that that
fight I'd rather see President Trump
who's a deal maker who can make things
happen take on woke corporations and I
know for a fact he gets results there
you go so Kerry Lake coming out and
saying I wonder how long it took her to
come up with that but if DeSantis de
sanctimonious if DeSantis can't beat
Donald Duck how is he going to beat
Donald Trump and she seems visibly proud
of that one so Kerry Lake auditioning
for VP and I actually think you're going
to see an interesting dynamic
where
even the people
that support Trump many of them they're
not going to be willing to do the
character assassination of Ron DeSantis
because big picture they actually like
him this idea that you would love Trump
but hate DeSantis they're sort of two
sides of the same coin so a lot of this
character assassination of one in favor
of the other is quite contrived the
reality is that on issues and positions
and culture War and the whole thing to
the extent that they take positions on
issues most people who like one of these
clowns would like the other that's the
reality and so when you see someone like
Carrie Lake draw these seemingly
insurmountable obvious glaring
distinctions between Trump and DeSantis
they're quite contrived and they're
usually for politically opportunistic
reasons bonus clip from Kerry Lake
she also said during the same appearance
other people are crazy and not live
living in reality which is quite Rich
for Kerry Lake to say who keeps
insisting any day she's going to be made
governor of Arizona the Mayors lost
their Collective mind have they not yeah
uh they're living on planet crazy and I
I don't frankly want to be on that same
planet with them because they well you'd
better find a flight out Carrie because
you've been on the planet for you're one
of the earliest Settlers of that planet
lost their minds you know they'll say
anything it shows you how desperate they
are they're just completely desperate
right now yeah
she seems to be describing herself and
her supporters she has no no ability to
analyze her own situation the mirrors
lost their Collective mind have they not
yeah they're living on planet crazy and
I I don't frankly want to be on that
same planet with them because they've
lost their minds you know they'll say
anything it shows you how desperate they
are they're just all right
um
so Kerry Lake uh is likely to be one of
the
is it is it impolite to say an attack
dog because Trump always talks about
they treated him like a dog uh she is
likely going to be one of the big
attackers of Ron DeSantis this is going
to continue and it will be very
interesting to see the aftermath tonight
in the meantime Trump immediately
jumping to attacking uh Ron DeSantis so
tonight Ron DeSantis will announce his
candidacy he has the audacity
to challenge Donald Trump's path to the
2024 Republican nomination Donald Trump
wasting no time and starting to post
even engaging caps lock to truth social
truth essential Trump posting as news
broke of Ron desantis's impending
candidacy quote look Rob de
sanctimonious came to me asking for help
he was losing badly by 31 points to
popular agriculture commissioner Adam
Putnam he was getting ready to drop out
of the race ran a terrible campaign Ron
told me he had one last chance my
support and endorsement which Putnam and
everyone else wanted also I gave it to
Ron and the race was over in one day he
went from losing badly to winning by a
lot it actually took four months but
okay who cares about the details with
three large Trump rallies he won the
general election in an upset disloyal
this is how Trump sees everything not
just politics and many Republicans see
it this way although maybe not to the
degree that Trump does I did something
for you
and now you should essentially have a
loyalty that is almost an indentured
servitude to me for the rest of your
political career you should never ever
ever run against me because I helped you
and and uh that is the sort of moral
Foundation to the extent that it is one
for Donald Trump trump continuing on
truth and then engaging caps lock here
quote Rhonda Sanctus can't win the
general election or get the nomination
because he voted to obliterate Social
Security even wanting to raise the
minimum age to 70 or more voted to badly
wound Medicare and fought hard and voted
for a 23 tax on everything sales tax he
wasn't is a disciple of horrible Rhino
Paul Ryan and others too many to mention
also he desperately needs a personality
transplant that's true and to the best
of my my knowledge they are not
medically available yet a disloyal
person Trump then continuing in all
capital letters I built the greatest
economy in the history of the world no
inflation energy Independence and soon
dominance the strongest border ever
record best employment numbers biggest
tax and regulation Cuts rebuilt our
military no Wars with Russia Ukraine or
China Taiwan or anywhere and the U.S was
respected all over the world what else
can I say almost everything there is a
lie and then one more truth all caps
short and sweet election interference so
if Trump is this triggered by the news
that DeSantis will be announcing his
candidacy tonight just you wait for what
Trump is going to do after tonight's
announcement this is going to be one of
the ugliest Republican primaries
that I've ever covered certainly but
maybe for an even longer period than
that I would expect videos I would
expect attacks interviews Furious
interviews hopefully with significant
audio trouble that's always the best but
we will be following all of it and I
hope you'll join me tonight shortly
before 6 PM Eastern 3 P.M Pacific we
will be covering the DeSantis
announcement
with Elon Musk Trump will probably
attack Elon Musk tonight as well uh it's
going to be wild and again the political
objective for me is for the ugliness of
the forthcoming Republican primary to be
as damaging as possible to whoever
eventually becomes the Republican
nominee likely Trump but maybe not also
Monday Memorial Day this is it guys
we're we're gonna do it Monday Memorial
Day we are launching a one day
membership special as many of you know
membership is the primary funding source
for this program we are going to
discount membership in order to entice
people hopefully you to sign up on
Monday all you need to do to take
advantage of this membership special is
get on my newsletter that's really it
you don't need to get anything notarized
you don't need to send any smoke signals
or fax anything anywhere you don't need
to build a Lego uh train or anything
like that you simply get on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com Monday
morning you'll be notified and then
everyone will be winning
it is Springtime it's getting warm we
are all spending more time outside many
sunscreens contain elements that the FDA
has warned about oxybenzone Ava benzone
homo sailate and others these are
absorbed into your bloodstream they can
irritate sensitive skin they can be
hormone disruptors I just stay away from
them and I use mineral sunscreens I do
the same when I put sunscreen on my baby
daughter and our sponsor Ginger armor
makes the world's thinnest 100 mineral
sunscreen it works for all skin types
not just gingers as the name might
suggest it rubs in clear on all skin
tones feels like nothing is on with SPF
50 plus protection Ginger armor also
acts as a plant-based moisturizer with
21 simple gentle ingredients from plants
and minerals it's good for you it's good
for the planet it's more affordable than
other sunscreens with similar quality
ingredients I also love that it's a
small business made in the U.S and they
donate one percent of all sales to the
one percent for the planet charity go to
gingerarmor.com use code Pacman for 15
off the link is down below
Nikki Haley is now not the only 2024
Republican primary candidate to fail at
answering the question how is it that
you were going to defeat Donald Trump in
this primary what are the differences
between you and Donald Trump in this
primary a South Carolina Republican
senator Tim Scott who announced his
candidacy uh which is completely dead on
arrival earlier this week he now was
asked on Fox News Trump's crushing the
polls how is that exactly will you
defeat him and Senator Tim Scott failed
or was unwilling to answer the question
in any real way I'm going to play the
clip for you he uses words I recognize
they're all English words that I can
Define I've heard these words before yet
he's not actually communicating anything
he either has no plan or he doesn't plan
to defeat Trump and maybe he's running
for vice president I don't exactly know
the strategy if there even is a strategy
here's Tim Scott and this is not a
winning strategy in the sense that it is
not a strategy at all have to go back to
the former president because his lead is
so mighty
how do you take on someone who literally
fights to fight I mean I I know you saw
2016 you saw 2020. Donald Trump is a
master at it what's your game plan
I can't find the simple one I'm running
for president United States and I plan
to be the nominee so the good news is
for the American people you will have a
star contrast between me and the rest of
the field I look forward to being the
messenger that actually adds to our
party without diluting our conservative
values okay was there an answer and
there the answer is no there was not uh
listen you um you how exactly are you
going to be doing brain transplant
surgery in five years when you're not in
medical school we don't have brain
transplant surgery as a procedure that
is done like how exactly are you going
to do it well listen five years are
going to go by and then I'm going to be
doing brain transplants oh wow I guess I
never thought about it that way that's
the absurdity of what Tim Scott is
saying here you're losing by 80. I mean
the numbers are completely ridiculous
how are you going to defeat Trump here
how are you going to get the support you
need I'm going to be the party's nominee
wow pretty amazing that you plan to do
that using words I recognize that don't
mean anything now I got a couple emails
from people saying what he means is I
plan to be Trump's vice president I
don't actually plan to win I'm really
running for vice president and the way
I'm going to do that is similar to the
Nikki Haley technique which is present
myself as an alternative
but don't really attack Trump
make it this kind of mild like well my
identity is different
um and then be there when it's time for
Donald Trump to choose his vice
president very low energy stuff a couple
other clips from Tim Scott yesterday on
Fox News here he um is asked about uh
contrast to other candidates he says
he's not going to talk about other
candidates it's going to make it tough
to win my friend I'm not going to focus
on the other candidates in this race I'm
going to focus on word we should keep
the fact it's on the American people too
many of us spend too much time talking
about ourselves there you go he's not
going to talk about himself or the other
candidates that's going to make it
really hard to win I mean I don't I
don't know how else to say it it will be
an extraordinarily difficult task to
convince more than 50 percent of
Republican primary voters to to choose
you over the other candidates when
you're polling one percent by not
talking about yourself nor the other
candidates that's really really really
strange and then he says the left is
quaking in their boots he keeps
repeating this I haven't heard one
person on the left say they're afraid of
Tim Scott here's what we're seeing the
radical left is quaking in their boots
because when an African-American
conservative who believes in the future
of this nation stands up to be counted
they push back that's a good sign we're
on the right message so I guess he's
saying the left is scared of him because
he's black which is a really strange
thing to say now that being said is he
going to run an identity campaign and
what I mean by that is Nikki Haley the
only things she really was willing to
draw a distinction with Trump on
seem to be that she's a woman and she's
younger and she's a person of color
maybe Tim Scott's plan is the same which
is I'm younger and I'm black I don't
know the problem is there's no evidence
that the Maga Republican party is
looking for a black candidate and I've
already explained to you why that is and
and that's gone back for a while so not
exactly a winning proposition and in the
meantime right-wing media and some uh
right-wing elected officials are
starting to do the mildly homophobic
attacks on Tim Scott and you might be
saying I didn't even know Tim Scott was
gay I don't know that he is but let's
talk about that next I'm gonna play a
clip for you here
of Ted Cruz being interviewed on Newsmax
and you're going to hear the Newsmax
host
say something that is becoming a story
about Tim Scott and it's a similar story
as it is with Lindsey Graham the other
Republican senator from South Carolina
and the way that Newsmax frames it is
that there are questions about Tim
Scott's personal life now you might be
saying what do you mean questions about
his personal life I need to be crystal
clear with you about what they mean here
they are starting to allude to the
possibility that Tim Scott is gay they
always dance around it I'll explain it
in a moment take a listen to this and
I'm and what if you're watching watch
Ted Cruz when this comes up glad for for
Tim's voice I think he's a very
important voice in the Senate and I'm
sure he will add a lot to this race yeah
so amazing life story personal story but
we don't know a lot about his personal
life and at some point those questions
will be asked as we make our way closer
to especially August the debate stage in
Milwaukee you have a comment on that oh
look I I'm sure that there will be nasty
political attacks between the different
candidates in the primary Ted Cruz is
like I know there are going to be nasty
political attacks because I'm planning
some particularly disgusting ones myself
that we can expect we've already seen
some of that uh and it's a rough and
tumble business that's that that's how
it operates okay so what are they
alluding to here I'll give you the back
story and understandably a lot of people
just haven't heard about this yet the
idea here is Tim Scott could be gay he
might be gay and the right is
speculating and the there are these
articles you know 57 year old Tim Scott
has never been married he's a sort of
Perpetual Bachelor blah blah blah blah
blah when he entered politics at age 30
he talked about being a virgin he
attributed it to his Christian faith or
something but it actually might be that
he's a gay man who is not
um was not comfortable saying that
publicly still isn't comfortable saying
that publicly now I have absolutely no
idea whether Tim Scott is gay there are
reports he's he's brought women to
events at times before it doesn't really
mean anything one way or the other I
don't actually care whether Tim Scott is
gay but the fascinating part
is that the right is setting up the
homophobic line and with Lindsey Graham
it's sort of the same thing but I
actually don't it's not exactly the same
I don't know where it stands right now
but with Lindsey Graham it's considered
more of one of these open Secrets also a
Perpetual Bachelor Lindsey Graham and
speculation or discussions that he's
actually a gay man uh why this wouldn't
just be something you say well I think
part of it has to do with you're a
senator in a Republican party that is
still extraordinarily homophobic and
that tells you a lot about why so as far
as Tim Scott goes they are starting to
prepare that line of attack you will not
see it brought out by candidates Trump
and DeSantis aren't going to on a debate
stage if Tim Scott makes it to a debate
stage attack him for being gay it's just
not gonna happen but
the packs and the dark money Etc if for
whatever reason Tim Scott actually
started getting some Traction in this
primary which he almost certainly will
not they can start doing the there are
questions about his personal life thing
it's been done to other candidates
before that's what's being alluded to
here it's a horrible thing uh it's
probably even more horrible that it has
the potential to impact voters within a
Republican primary we will follow it and
that's what they're teeing up all of
these clips that I've been playing the
Newsmax Ted Cruz clip about Tim Scott or
the earlier Clips with Tim Scott on Fox
all of these clips we make these
available on our Instagram which you can
find by searching Instagram for
davidpackman show we also post them to
our Tick Tock which you can find by
searching Tick Tock for David Pacman
show and of course we make them
available on our YouTube channel if you
can find it youtube.com forward slash
not backslash forward slash the David
Pacman show we're going to take a very
short break and the show continues right
after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
just when you think the entire Arizona
gubernatorial Fiasco involving Kerry
Lake can't get any more embarrassing
Carrie Lake yesterday was begging for
money desperate desperate claiming that
she's going to fight on despite the fact
that a judge has dismissed her final
challenge in her election loss for
Arizona governor back in November Now
understand that it has now been seven
months almost since she lost and when I
say she lost It's always important to
clarify what I mean is her opponent
Katie Hobbs received more votes judge
this this is a PBS report
from the Associated Press judge
dismisses Kerry Lake's last challenge in
election loss for Arizona governor a
judge on Monday dismissed the only
remaining legal claim in Republican
Kerry Lake's challenge of her loss last
year to Katie Hopps Maricopa County
superior judge Peter Thompson said Lake
failed to prove her claim that Maricopa
County did not verify signatures on mail
ballots as required by law this was the
final challenge so what does Kerry Lake
do yesterday she holds another one of
these delusional press conferences where
she comes up with reams of paper and
there's people standing behind her we
never know who the hell these people are
or what role they have in any of this
and then she begs for money she begs for
money
here's one here's one dear Kerry my
humble 20 donation for your continued
fights against the evils at the Arizona
and D.C cartels wow
this is a 20 check this came from Sun
City West wow I mean I guys I could go
through this whole thing this these
letters
move me to tears yeah
the real reason she's crying is no no
judges are buying her BFS into tears
what's going on in our elections and the
people
are the ones who are helping us they
want they want our case to go forward
they want to keep sending money just to
fight this because they know if we don't
fight this now we're losing our country
it's not fun I I have been offered
bribes to get out of politics there's
that story where which was never
verified and no details were ever
provided
we have such a huge movement they're
afraid of this movement being back on
the ballot
true Bram they're afraid of this
movement being back on the ballot I've
actually had someone show up at my door
pretty powerful person offer me money to
not run sure office again they don't
want my name on the ballot they're that
scared of her offered me whatever I
wanted to put our movement on ice for
two years
we are going to continue to take
donations if people can it seems as
though you have quite literally no more
legal recourse are you still going to
collect donations absolutely I I'm not
here begging for donations guys that's
actually exactly that's quite literally
what she's doing
it's difficult putting food on the table
right now in Joe Biden's economy it's
very difficult so let me put aside as
she says this she puts aside she
realizes I should stop begging for
donations by taking envelopes out of
this bag of donut box of donations I
have so she puts it to the side as she
says I'm not here begging for donations
well I guess not in the next 10 seconds
asking for donations I want you to all
know that I am asking for people to get
involved Marissa is going to help
motivated excuse me excuse me just a
minute the people who do make donations
is going toward paying for a legal fund
oh so so you'll take them and you have a
use for them that's great the how would
I want to meet the person donating to
Cary lake at this point in time what on
Earth could be going through your mind
if anything
for you to at this point say hey you
know what I think I'm gonna send Carrie
Lake money I'm gonna send her money at
this point in time I'm not here begging
for donations I'm merely talking about
how great the people sending money are
and reminding people we will continue
accepting donations but I'm not begging
for them now I guess in order to provide
some cover
plot even ostensibly for accepting
donations Kerry Lake now says she wants
to take this to the Supreme Court where
even this delusional right-wing Supreme
Court I don't think is going to hear
this case Newsweek reports former
Arizona gubernatorial candidate Kerry
Lake on Tuesday announced her intention
to keep pushing her election case
towards the Supreme Court after
suffering a major loss in court she made
the announcement after a judge ruled
that her legal team did not have
sufficient evidence to prove ballot
workers didn't conduct the signature
matching
um her challenges were consistently
dismissed in court including Mondays but
she pledged to continue fighting she
will try to prove her argument before
The Supreme Court she also all she often
makes this vague claim we proved our
elections are a mess we proved signature
verification is a joke she said she
wasn't surprised by the judge's decision
Lake also announced a new ballot chasing
initiative which he says was the largest
in Arizona Zona this involves reaching
out to registered voters and assuring
they submit the ballots on time all this
sort of stuff so listen bottom line this
is going nowhere this is a complete and
total human accumulation but at the end
of the day the only reason that these
things last as long as they do the only
reason Kerry lake is still doing this
stuff after seven months is because
someone is donating money to her let me
give you a counter imagine a different
scenario imagine that on November 15th
or whenever it was that Kerry Lake first
announced that this was going to
continue for so long imagine no one
donated money to her
she wouldn't continue doing this for
seven months the reason that this
continues is that people continue to
donate money some people clearly people
who don't understand anything and uh my
guess is that many of the people sending
her money can't actually afford to do so
which is probably the saddest part of
this entire thing so is it finally over
yes and also now she's pushing for the
Supreme Court let's hope that doesn't
happen radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green now
has made the very brave declaration that
she refused to wear the covid vaccine
I don't know what on Earth that means
either she filmed this video alongside
her new partner Brian Glenn that's the
dude who always looks sunburned and
stoned during the Trump rallies on right
side broadcasting network and interviews
people they are now together much
speculation about whether Glenn is
responsible for the breakup of Marjorie
Taylor Green's marriage don't know don't
really care but they both now are
talking about masks and vaccines
Marjorie Taylor green says she never
wore the vaccine and her boyfriend
actually seems to dodge the vaccine
question when she says you know you're
not vaccinated he seems to skip over
that and only talk about masks which is
kind of interesting take a look at this
well and I'll be upfront and honest with
you
um I'm not vaccinated I always refuse to
wear the vaccine and and I wore mask a
little bit some of the time but it got
to a certain point where I refused the
mask as well Brian you're not vaccinated
you you're not you I didn't want to wear
the mask at all and a lot of times in
the airport I was asked to put it on and
I would for a second and I would take it
off yes there you go very very proud and
Powerful Act of defiance so anyway he
just skips over whether or not he's
vaccinated but she says she won't wear
the vaccine tin foil hats she'll gladly
wear but the vaccine she's not willing
to strap onto herself so what I think is
the most important you know we
as we continue to just learn and get
more information about everything that
went on in the covet era there's
learning for everybody to do you know
the the original vaccine very effective
at preventing transmission the more
recent versions of the vaccine against
the more recent variants
almost completely ineffective at
preventing transmission still very good
at preventing illness or death and
reducing the odds that you end up uh in
the hospital okay so we're learning
about that one of the things that we're
also learning about is the hypocrisy
that knows no bounds from members of the
Republican party and people like
Marjorie Taylor green they cry about
masks and how mask requirements are
discriminatory and they're potentially
illegal they love to say etc etc but
they are completely on board
with this systematic
push for laws that discriminate against
LGBT people and folks who aren't
Christian and women telling them you
don't have any right to decide for
yourself with medical professionals what
is right for you and your family we're
going to tell you no abortion it's going
to be against the law and we might even
prosecute you or the doctor or whoever
if you try to procure an abortion the
this idea of discrimination you're
discriminating against me by saying I
have to wear a mask or to the extent
that there were vaccine requirements at
certain points in time the the
businesses are the ones now
discriminating wait a second you have
been pushing a politics for decades of
letting businesses do whatever they want
you don't even want many of these folks
don't even want protected classes of
people they always say listen a business
should be allowed to say we don't serve
black people or gay people and then
customers can choose not to patronize
that business if they don't like that
policy for decades they've been saying
don't restrict what businesses can do
all of a sudden businesses say well some
of us are going to require a vaccine or
some of us are going to require oh
that's that should be illegal you're
discriminating against people who don't
want to wear a mask or shouldn't wear a
mask because of carbon dioxide
conspiracies or whatever the case may be
the hypocrisy knows no bounds even on
serious issues that they claim to be at
the top of the uh policy questions that
they believe our government should be
dealing with so they are hypocrites many
of them are also Liars you know that I I
go back to the Tucker Carlson ranting
against the vaccines for so long he and
his family almost certainly vaccinated
Fox News had that policy in place where
if you weren't vaccinated they really
made your your day-to-day pretty tough
and he never mentioned he was being
subjected to it so they often lie they
are hypocrites but the real victims are
the people who don't really know any
better and they follow them and they
believe the things they say and they
make decisions that are disastrous for
their own families and I'm not talking
about necessarily even medical decisions
I'm talking about economic decisions
employment all sorts of decisions the
people spouting the nonsense don't
suffer but those who have Fox News and
Marjorie Taylor Green's podcast and real
America's voice as their primary news
sources those are the folks that suffer
at the end of the day
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show 36 year
old divorce grandmother and Republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert appeared on
a panel yesterday Congressional hearing
about the high cost of prescription
drugs an important issue and she
declared during this uh hearing that the
reason she had a third child is because
birth control was too expensive so she
opted to leave the pharmacy without
paying for the prescription I yes having
unprotected sex leading to this third
child that she ultimately had now there
are factual inaccuracies here there are
moral conundrums here let's listen to
the clip first and then we're going to
discuss it Mike um but do you see that
patients leave their prescriptions at
pharmacies because
be long or pay for it they absolutely do
in my Pharmacy yes that happens
um more than should make anyone come out
I actually have a fun little story my
staff is probably going to talk to me
about this later but uh I left a
prescription at a pharmacy once
um I went to get birth control and I was
there at the counter and went to pay for
it and the the price was very very high
I said wow is this a three six month
prescription no ma'am this is one month
and I said it's cheaper to have a kid
wow and I left it there and now I have
my third son Caden bobert um and so I'm
actually it was it was turned out to be
a really great thing but um I've
personally experienced that when times
were tough but um thank you so much for
your Indulgence there and talk to the
team about that comment later oh my
team's gonna get me in trouble because I
told an insane story so there's a lot
here there's a there is a lot here
there's Lauren bobert's legislative
hypocrisy
there are the factual inaccuracies as
well so first and foremost Lauren bobert
has been a staunch opponent of abortion
and Reproductive Rights she's voted
against expanding access to
contraception for millions of Americans
who need it and potentially are in the
position she was once in where paying
for the birth control is expensive so
she has been someone who if this story
is true
she understands how difficult it can be
and she has voted against making it
easier to access birth control for uh
millions of Americans she also seems
completely oblivious to the fact that
raising a kid is way more expensive than
paying completely out of pocket for the
birth control pills which with most
insurance plans now are actually free
anyway but forget about that for a
second
the research I've done suggests that out
of pocket
birth control is about 50 bucks a month
50 bucks a month the estimated cost of
raising a child to age 18 most recently
was two hundred and thirty three
thousand dollars now that's a
six-year-old number inflation might make
it even higher at this point in time
that depends on a lot of different
things including uh standard of living
and geographical location all these
different things if you pay the 50 bucks
a month or six hundred dollars per year
for birth control out of pocket even
over 18 years if you were on
out-of-pocket birth control for 18 years
that's 10 grand compared to at least two
hundred and thirty three thousand
dollars to raise a kid so what she's
saying is also very stupid and it
actually makes me wonder did she really
believe that is Lauren bobert so bad at
either math or or reality
that when she saw wow it's gonna be 50
bucks for these birth control pills did
she really do some math that came out
with her thinking it's cheaper to have a
kid and to pay the costs of having a kid
for 18 years I don't know it's a level
of stupidity that really is uh shocking
and then there's the moral aspect here
as well she's essentially saying I
didn't even want this third kid but I
ended up having this third kid because I
had unprotected sex because I couldn't
afford the birth control and therefore I
didn't even actually want this kid
although she's saying he's a good kid I
like the kid it reminds me of producer
Lewis who once said if I accidentally
had a kid I'd probably love the kid it
seems like she ends up loving her kid
but she's saying essentially that she
didn't want that kid either which I know
is not uh there are many parents who
would have stories like this but the
funny little story that Lauren bobert
told is an extraordinarily disturbing
example of how out of touch she is with
the reality of what it costs to raise a
kid what it costs to pay for birth
control completely seemingly morally
disconnected
from what I would call a responsibility
that she has as a member of Congress to
okay you know of a problem that you
experienced you could vote to prevent
other people from having that very same
problem but she doesn't instead she
votes to make it more difficult to
access that very same thing truly and
absolutely disgusting and also seemingly
a clueless person
we have now learned that Donald Trump's
first criminal trial we don't know if
there will be more than one we will see
Trump's first criminal trial has been
set for March of 2024 and this is going
to be taking place right in the middle
of the 2024 presidential election right
when the
um Republican electorate may be choosing
or close to choosing their nominee for
2024 and this could be absolute and
total chaos this Republican primary is
already going to be I believe the most
insane I will have ever covered with Ron
DeSantis announcing tonight that he is
entering the race Trump already
massively triggered by that news I
believe that this is going to be a
completely Bonkers primary
it could become even Crazier by what we
learned from CNN yesterday A New York
judge has set a trial date of March 25
2024 for the criminal case against
former president Donald Trump
potentially setting up a media spectacle
in the middle of the Republican primary
yeah I think it's more than just the
potential to create a spectacle the
trial date was set during a brief
hearing Tuesday in which the judge read
Trump an order on what he can and cannot
say publicly about the case I'm sure
Trump is going to abide by that right
Trump appeared remotely via video feed
so the judge could communicate with him
in open court remember that Trump
pleaded not guilty last month the 34
felony counts we talked about that we
covered it live during the hearing Trump
could be seen speaking and gesturing to
his attorney Todd Blanche sitting next
to him but audio was not audible at
times he sat back with his arms crossed
the former president only spoke to
confirm he had a copy of the protective
order yes I do he said Trump's attorney
said that the former president remains
concerned that the order infringes on
his first amendment rights quote he
understands he has to comply with the
order and if he doesn't do so he's
violating your order
Merchant reiterated that's the judge
that there is not a gag order in place
Trump can publicly defend himself
against the allegations saying it is
certainly not my intention to impede
Trump's ability to campaign for
president he's free to defend himself
he's free to campaign he is free to do
just about anything that does not
violate the specific terms of the
protective order and said if he does
violate that order he could end up being
sanctioned this is going to be
completely bonkers the next hearing is
January for so the timeline is as
follows defense motions are due a couple
of days before the end of August
prosecutors must respond by the 10th of
October the next hearing is January 4th
2024 which might be the first court date
of 2024 January 4th no that's a Thursday
um and then this is all going to uh move
forward to trial reportedly in March now
there is one motion filed by Trump's
lawyers which could completely upend
this Trump's lawyer this is from the
same CNN article Trump's lawyers have
filed a motion to move the criminal case
to Federal Court
arguing that these crimes are tied to
Trump's duties as president the defense
request to move the case to Federal
Court doesn't pause the state Court's
schedule a hearing in federal court is
scheduled for next month
so this there are so many ifs ands and
buts about when and how this is actually
going to go forward if it does get moved
to federal court it's going to be a
completely different situation that then
we will have to potentially have a new
schedule from the ground up if this
schedule remains
this could end up all leading to a trial
of former president Donald Trump a
criminal trial on 34 felony counts as
mathematically Trump is locking up the
Republican nomination or maybe not right
the question is if Trump does get
arrested again sometime between July and
September by Fannie Willis and maybe
there will be more charges coming from
the Mar-A-Lago uh documents Fiasco on
and on
this may this may destroy Trump's
chances even beforehand but imagine that
things stay as they look right now Trump
with an easy lead over Ron DeSantis but
Ron DeSantis stays in maybe even wins a
couple primaries maybe DeSantis wins the
Florida Republican primary and a couple
others in March March into April when
this trial may be happening
the guy who is on trial for 34 criminal
counts could at that exact same time be
securing the Republican nomination what
will that be like I don't know
completely unprecedented and at this
point we will wait and see whether the
trial is moved to Federal Court we have
a voicemail number that number is 2192
David P
uh we got a voicemail from our old
friend Eric from Mass
and he is moving on from anti-vaxx to
anti-trans and he makes some claims
that don't make any sense that I
actually want to spend some time talking
about listen to this they're about trans
kids and gay kids hey David Fell from
Mass um that was a funny video gay
children trans guilt there's no such
thing
yeah I think back when you were a kid
no such thing as gay children trans
children what do you mean that's an
adult being thing
Maybe 16.
we running around uh you're gay or
you're running around sleeping with uh
kids when you were eight nine ten eleven
twelve I mean four girls maybe if you
try that once or twice doubt it no such
thing as gay children or trans children
it's ridiculous you're he's moved the
goal post next it'll be they're trying
to do gay babies now I mean trans babies
three-year-old transition okay so I I
happen I happen to be heterosexual I I
happen not to be gay but I knew that
at quite an early age
um
my gay friends who I've talked to about
this say oh no I I knew that I was gay
when I was very young most of them say
five or six
um and I think that that I I mean as I
think back I think I knew I was
heterosexual at age five or six at least
that's as far back as I can remember
Eric from Mass seems to think that the
sort of default status for everyone is
heterosexuality and at age end and uh
cisgender gender identity meaning that
your gender identity just it aligns with
your biological sex at Birth until age
16 and suddenly 16th birthday you go oh
you know what actually I'm gay actually
I'm trans and of course this is
ridiculous now there's a separate
question which is a legitimate question
about what age limits should there be on
certain aspects to transition when we're
talking about medication versus surgical
versus there are all sorts of realistic
and practical good faith questions that
should be explored by the medical
community
about that much like as I say many times
I don't think I have the answers when it
comes to transports on every sport and
any situation I don't I'm not pretending
to have the answer but what I do know is
that the bathroom fear mongering is
actually nonsense what I do know is that
everyone should be treated with respect
what I do know is that calling somebody
by a different name that they want to be
called or using different pronouns is
really no big deal one way or the other
and it almost is boring to me and what I
mean by that is when I say it's boring
sometimes people misunderstand what I
say I don't mean that I don't care about
the plight of folks whose identity isn't
being respected or recognized by Society
that's not what I mean what I mean is
there are so many other issues that I
actively believe we need to work on
inequality wages climate change
education Etc that having to talk about
what pronouns someone wants to go by or
whether they're going to wear a dress or
whatever it's just such a distraction
it's not a distraction to advocate for
people to be treated uh properly and so
I want to make clear that I'm making a
distinction there but this unfortunately
this view that Eric presents here
um when it is believed it leads to
unfortunate treatment of people and this
was an issue you know I remember back in
the the days you know when I would
interview the Westboro Baptist Church
people this is like 10 over 10 years ago
now and gay marriage was like the big
battle line on um issues of sexual
orientation and gender you had this
argument people are either born gay or
uh it is a choice that was often the
dichotomy and what underlied that
argument was often that some folks
asserted if it's a choice we should be
able to treat LGBT people like crap
because they're merely choosing that
sort of like you might choose to be goth
or whatever the case may be and what was
often lost there was
even if it were a choice of which for
which there is no evidence but even if
it if even if any of these things are
choices
why would we treat anyone like crap why
would we discriminate against anybody uh
as a society it still doesn't make any
sense and that's much of what underlies
this sort of thing with people like Eric
from Mass and uh and others which is if
they they think if they can convince
society that all of these identities are
merely things that people choose in
their teens either for attention or
because they believe it's mental illness
or whatever then as a society we would
be free to treat these folks terribly
and that's maybe the saddest part of it
all because we shouldn't be treating
anybody like crap I think is the
takeaway that I want to go to so another
disturbing voicemail from Eric from Mass
that serves as an insight
into what is malfunctioning in the
brains of many of these anti-trans
people we've got a great bonus show for
you today I can't wait for it
um target has decided to remove some of
their pride month merchandise after
receiving threats yeah they seem to be
capitulating secondly social media is
driving the Teen Mental Health crisis
the Surgeon General is warning as if we
didn't already know that but we have
even more data now that we're going to
look at I'm actually going to tell
people about now having a baby even
though we're nowhere near this phase I
have been thinking a lot about what is
my policy going to be on social media
and smartphone use and Cal Newport has
an interesting episode about this on his
podcast recently Jonathan height has
talked about it a lot to talk about and
lastly there is a new survey whose
results are surprising to some which
finds that veterans are less likely to
support extremist movements of any kind
there's often the assumption that
military vets are more extreme
politically but the survey suggests
something different we're going to look
at it of course it looks at averages all
of those stories and more are on today's
bonus show which I invite you to access
by signing up at joinpakman.com or
making a pledge on patreon at
patreon.com the davidpackman show bonus
show coming up today new show tomorrow
will do the aftermath of the DeSantis
announcement and so many other things
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors it's good to wear
sunscreen year round but it is really
the time of year for sunscreen right now
you may have heard FDA warnings about
chemical sunscreens which can cause skin
irritation and other issues that's why
it's best to use a mineral sunscreen
like the one by Ginger armor it is just
as effective much safer and you'll save
15 percent with the code Pacman the link
is down below